one can talk about all the isms all day
long and and communism and socialism are
a consequence of liberalism you know
centuries ago but even just the libs
have this problem which is liberalism
boils down to maximizing individual
autonomy and what that boils down to I
mean we see this in the absurdities of
all the identity ideologies that have
proliferated today but what that boils
down to is a diminishing of the
importance of objective reality of
things like law of things like I don't
know real estate prices relative to Palm
Beach but all of these things that that
goes away I mean if if a man can claim
that he is a type of thing that he is
not and be granted uh you know that that
right in society then we're untethered
from reality and so maximum individual
expression makes the law into nothing
more than a a way to wield a cudgel and
beat your enemies